guys let's face it playing fantasy
football is a pain in the ass you got to
spend hours and hours researching for a
draft then if you forget to set your
lineups for one week your whole season
is screwed not to mention fantasy season
doesn't even include the NFL playoffs
the best part that's why you should
switch to prize picks it's so simple
just pick two or more players every week
and decide whether you think they will
get more or less than their projected
numbers here's my picks for this week if
you miss a week or two weeks or 3 weeks
it doesn't matter and what's even better
you can play all the way to the Super
Bowl and what's best if you use a promo
code aach right now when you sign sign
up they will match your initial deposit
up to $100 that means you put in 100 you
get 100 for free it's a no- brainer and
this week you get a free Square
Christian mcaffrey more or less than a
half a yard that's obviously more I'm
giving you one so guys go to prix.com
sign up it's the best so much better
then rooting for a team whose owner
decides to also be general manager and
drives the franchise into the ground no
matter what the people who were born and
raised in that City might think I'm not
naming any names I'm just saying
price.com promo code aash loyalty is
important I will actually never root for
the ners but the